(energetic dubstep music)
(whistles)
- That's a charge!
You see Big Momma's House?
What's your favorite
Will Smith movie?
(grunts)
(loud thud)
(horn honks)
It's a foul.
All right, kids,
all right, kids!
(laughs) Now we're
having fun already.
Let's push it up, push
it up, push it up!
What are you guys getting up
to after the game tonight?
You know, you go to Red Robin?
What are you guys gonna do?
(whistles)
You guys got lunch plans?
You guys...
What table you guys sit at?
Smells good in there, what
are you guys having tonight?
- Mac and cheese.
- You know what gets me going?
Stroganoff, beef Stroganoff.
You want it to be sweet?
Southern belle?
Well, I never.
I'll do that all day!
Yeah, I'm not sure if I
wanna be a top or a bottom.
I guess I'll find out
when the guys show up.
I'm not a...
No, oh no.
Trust me, I had plenty
of opportunities
in prison to do that.
You know, I got a group of
guys and I could connect with.
We're locked in here together.
You know what I also
wish for is a new family.
And I feel like I have,
(clears throat) I feel like
I have that with you guys.
(blows)
- Oh god.
(energetic dubstep music)